Một tháng 2, giới trực yên ràng tin bố chương trình tên lửa là Lan Zeng Đỏ và sẽ không năm trong bất kỳ quân khổ đả phản nào với Mỹ.
Trong bữ cảnh hai bên trình bị cho gòn bữ thận mới.
Cú thể theo Ali Sám Khà Nyi, câu vẫn của lãnh tụi tụi gạo yên ràng Ali Khà Minh Lai.
Nó lực tên lửa của Tây Héran là không thể tương lợp.
Và trường à bác sẽ rắc chỉ cũng cho biết, vẫn để tên lửa trước từ năm trong trực trực nghĩ dựa và sẽ không được tương lợp với kế Mỹ.
Tên bố lực lửa ra sau các cuộc tiếp xúc giữa Mỹ và Iran Phải Phô Man Còn trước,
Washington nhiều lần kêu góa mở giọc đàn phản hạnh nhân,
sang trực trình tên lửa và hỏng đậu của các người nửa uống nhẹp,
tại chúng đông giọt Iran Hổ Thun.
Ví dụ như Hà Más và Hà Bô Lá,
tổng tổ Mỹ tuần Tram Cảnh Báo,
có thể ám dụng vệ pháp chất mạnh, nếu không đặt được phần.
Trong khi thu tương Iran Benjamin, ra ra hụt,
dự kiến cũng sẽ gặp ông Tram trong ngày 12, 2 tháng 2.